[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy vamos a hablar de sudán del
sur un país al noreste de áfrica que
cumple 10 años de independencia luego de
haberse separado de sudán el 9 de julio
de 2011 la autodeterminación lograda
tras un histórico referendo lo convierte
en el estado soberano más joven del
mundo pero también precipitó su división
política exhibió su profunda rivalidad
étnica y lo condenó a una penosa guerra
civil en julio de 2013 la lucha de poder
entre el presidente salva kiir y el
vicepresidente real machar detonó una
pugna entre las etnias 5 y 9 las
diferencias interétnicas ardieron en
diciembre de ese año con una guerra que
se extendió hasta el 2018 el conflicto
entre las fuerzas armadas leales al
presidente que ir y las tropas rebeldes
protectoras del exvicepresidente marchar
se propagó por todo el país dejó decenas
de miles de muertos más de dos millones
de desplazados y un
hambruna generalizada
la guerra civil que este país tuvo que
atravesar en apenas 10 años de
independencia se pudo saldar con un
acuerdo de paz promovido por la onu pero
calificadores internacionales dicen que
es muy frágil una fragilidad que de
hecho incluyó a sudan del sur en el
índice de estados fallidos realizado por
el centro de estudios estadounidense
fondo para la paz así que nos surge la
pregunta de dónde proviene este estado
tan joven y tan convulso el territorio
de sudán del sur fue colonizado durante
los siglos 15 y 19 por las migraciones
de pueblos nilo ticos
o sea habitantes del valle centro y
superior del río nilo pobladores
espigados y de gran estatura con
culturas predominantemente africanas y
de creencias animistas y cristianas un
pueblo compuesto de varias tribus pero
disímil a sus vecinos del norte en el
siglo 19 hablamos de los árabes de fe
musulmana que ocupaban el territorio de
egipto un estado por entonces vasallo
del imperio otomano
desde mediados de 1800 el imperio
otomano comenzó a flaquear en su
soberanía y permitió la penetración del
imperio británico en los territorios de
egipto
los ingleses hallaron que para 1820 los
egipcios habían invadido las tierras al
sur de el río nilo en lo que actualmente
se conoce como sudán y sudán del sur
el avance colonizador de los británicos
fue prontamente aceptado por los
habitantes del actual sudan mientras que
los sureños del territorio impusieron
bastante resistencia ante la dicotomía
encontrada los ingleses prefirieron
dedicar sus esfuerzos para desarrollar y
modernizar las tierras del norte
mientras que en el sur apenas procuraron
mantener el orden en una región ya de
por sí afectada por el rapto de
pobladores esclavizados por los egipcios
pese a la unidad del territorio se
dividió en dos administraciones en el
norte prevaleció el idioma árabe y en el
sur se implementó el inglés
con la independencia de egipto entre
1922 y 1923 el territorio de sudán
comenzó a bascular entre varios
intereses de una parte de los egipcios
querían incluirlo en su demarcación
los británicos antes de entregárselo a
egipto pensaron en adherir la parte sur
al protectorado de uganda y los propios
sudaneses a su vez buscaban segregarse
como un solo país tras la segunda guerra
mundial y el declive del colonialismo
europeo en áfrica egipcios y británicos
acordaron darle la independencia a sudán
y formarlo como una república en 1956
con jartúm como capital es la noción de
un solo sudan desde 1955 detonó las
crispaciones interétnicas al sur de
sudán así comenzó la primera guerra
civil sudanesa que enfrentó al recién
declarado gobierno central contra el
movimiento de liberación sureño esta
primera guerra duró 17 años y terminó en
1972 luego de negociar
addis abeba la capital de etiopía la
creación de un nuevo gobierno autónomo
en el sur de sudán la paz lograda per
duró apenas una década hasta que el
presidente sudanés yaafar al no mary de
raíces árabes y fe musulmana quiso
aplicar la sharia en todo el país es
decir una interpretación extremista del
islam con lo cual abocó al país a una
segunda guerra civil sudanesa este
conflicto entre el gobierno central de
sudán y el ejército de liberación del
pueblo de sudán se extendió hasta el
2005 cuando se logró un nuevo acuerdo de
paz en dicho acuerdo se revivió la
figura de un gobierno autónomo de sudán
del sur por seis años cuando se convoca
a un referéndum secesionista con un 98
83 por ciento el referendo separatista
de 2011 dejó clara la voluntad del
pueblo sur sudanés de erigirse como un
nuevo país el gobierno de jartúm aceptó
la decisión y se dio la
autodeterminación de yubá
entonces en sudan del sur las cicatrices
de la más reciente guerra civil perduran
los hospitales del país siguen
recibiendo heridos por los conflictos
tribales y las esperanzas de los jóvenes
se diluyen por un ineficiente sistema
educativo y un escaso mercado laboral
además del país más joven del mundo
después de diez años de independencia
vive una de las peores hambrunas de la
región que afecta a más de 4 millones de
habitantes organismos internacionales
insisten que la paz lograda hace tan
solo tres años es muy frágil y en
cualquier momento puede romperse así
concluimos hoy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]